this is daniela roos
director of mit c cell and deputy dean
of research
at the schwartzman college of computing
and i'm excited to welcome you to the
latest installment
of hot topics in computing today
we'll be chatting uh with an important
thought leader
in in technology and in particular
in the area of fake data
and this is professor hani farid
professor farid is now on faculty at
uc berkeley but several years ago we
were
colleagues and friends in the computer
science department at dartmouth college
hani is also a member of the broader mit
community
as he was a postdoc here and i would
like to
introduce hani's postdoc advisor
professor ted aylson
who will introduce our speaker ted take
it away please
thanks uh so it is my
pleasure to introduce honey fareed
um he has the distinction of
being one of the few people where you
can say he invented his own field
uh which is digital image forensics
uh i'm pleased to be able to say i was
there
when he invented this field uh but i had
nothing to do with this
myself i was in my lab working on
various
more traditional image processing topics
uh and human vision and computer vision
and one of the great things about hani
at that time and
still today is that he has very diverse
interests and skills he's interested in
everything and that has turned out to be
really important uh for the work he's
done
um he was uh
so this is um just a little before 2000
1998 or so
uh and people were aware that this the
issue of finding manipulation and fake
images
was going to be an important image but
nobody really an important issue
nobody really knew what to do about it
uh connie had some ideas i encouraged
him to pursue them
but when he told me what he was trying
to do and how he was going to do it i
explained to him why it wouldn't work
and i cited the
relevant theorems and
offered counter examples um but he
uh persisted and finally uh
when he demonstrated it worked i i was
convinced and i
um was delighted and and i also saw him
give a uh
poster soon thereafter at a conference
explaining what he was doing
and um a you know a famous professor
came to the poster
started with a frown explain to honey
why it wouldn't work
cited the theorems and the math of why
it wouldn't work
and then continued through the poster
and as he continued in the poster
he started smiling until at the end he
was like wow that's really cool
uh and occasionally at the conference i
would go back to see tahani's poster and
i would watch
as the next person go through the same
thing starting with the front ending
with
oh wow that's really cool uh
and so this is i think typified what
hani's done
through the years is uh time and again
through his uh broad interests and
skills and creativity
uh constantly found ways to do things
that everyone thought was impossible
and everyone could prove was impossible
and he continues to do that today
and it do it in so many interesting ways
and as we all know these problems have
become really
critical today so it will be very
interesting to hear what
hani is working on now
take it away thanks ted it's great
seeing you and daniella wonderful to see
you after all these years i'm only sorry
um it's not in person um
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
some of the most recent work that we've
been doing so hopefully you have me in
full screen i think you're in full
screen now
um and the work i'm going to talk about
for most of the talk is that
of shuchi agarwal who's a really
terrific phd student in my lab
graduating next year she's going to be
on the job market soon so everybody
should pay attention she is
really really wonderful we're going to
talk about deep fake videos you may have
heard this term i'll define it for you
in a minute
but let me just start with the obvious
and where ted sort of started
is that image manipulation is not new
i mean as long as we've been taking
photographs we've been manipulating
photographs this of course is a
photograph of stalin
the gentleman to stalin's left had
fallen out of favor
um and stalin apparently uh thought that
he could just
wipe this person out of history by
airbrushing
him out of the photo and so how do they
do this well this is obviously
pre-digital and so this is done
in a dark room you take the negative and
you literally paint over
and then you re-image and you can alter
a photograph
and one of the questions about and
stalin wasn't alone by the way you can
look throughout history you see evidence
of photo manipulation
and one of the interesting questions you
want to ask yourself is well well why
why did stalin go to the trouble why not
just knock the guy off and be done with
it
and i posit that it's because people
like stalin
understood the power of photography
they understood the power of visual
imagery which is that if you can change
images
you can change history and while the
underlying techniques for manipulating
images have changed dramatically
over the the decades that fundamental
concept that there is
power in visual imagery i don't think
has changed
now fast forward to the digital age and
we can do lots
of fun things with digital images and
things like photoshop
so relatively easy to create the photo
like this where trump's face was
spliced onto the body of a child that
former president obama is holding and
we've been able probably to do this for
about 10 15 20 years and
and as ted was saying when i was working
with ted
two by the way of the best years of my
career um
you know photoshop was really in its
infancy film still dominated the
landscape and i remember ted and i
sitting in his
office looking at a graph showing the
the sales of film cameras and digital
cameras and just around the time
uh in the late 90s early 2000s was the
tipping point
it was at the 50 mark where film was on
the way down and digital was on the way
up and that's when i started thinking
about
well what happens when we enter a
landscape and everything is digital
and you can start manipulating digital
media
and that sort of led on to a two-decade
a question of authenticating digital
media
and what happened over the that two
decade is for the first decade or so
it was really digital cameras photoshop
and things like this
and i remember talking to ted about this
many years ago maybe five years ago and
ted was saying
you know this is a great little field
it's a niche field
um and you know it's important but it
was small
and it was true but something weird has
happened over the last five years
with the misinformation apocalypse that
is the inf
that is the internet now and the role of
fake images and fake videos and fake
content
and suddenly what seemed to be a
relatively small field has become much
much larger and we'll talk a little bit
more about where i see that
in the coming years but in particular
what has happened
most recently in the last few years is
that we have gone from
manipulating things in the dark room to
simple manipulations in photoshop
to full-blown synthesis using advances
in machine learning and big data
so we're going to talk about this in
particular so if you navigate to this
person does not exist.com
you will be presented with a single
image of a person these are
six images that i grabbed off of that
website
and these are people who don't exist um
they are completely full-blown
synthesized by
uh deep learning uh in particular
generative adversarial network which
i'll talk about in
more detail in a minute unlike cgi
unlike computer generated imagery where
you have a 3d model and a virtual camera
and virtual light and texture and hair
and highly highly detailed that's not
this this is a purely data-driven
image based technique for synthesizing
images of people who don't exist
and that idea of computer synthesizing
images
or video or audio is what is broadly
called
deep think so let's talk about how these
are made very quickly
it's a pretty simple idea your job is to
generate an image
with a face of a person who doesn't
exist
and the way we do that is we have a
generator the generator job is to create
an image they start by generating
a random image slap down a bunch of
pixels on whatever resolution you want
hand that image over to a discriminator
that discriminator has access to a bunch
of faces of
actual people scraped from the internet
some database whatever it is
and the discriminator's job is to ask
can i discriminate
this image handed by the the generator
from these images that are known to be
real people and of course that would be
a trivial task to do in this case
because that's a bunch of random pixels
loops back to the generator says nope
it's not a person keep
trying again and eventually after enough
iterations the generator
will eventually make an image of a
person that person will be sent to the
discriminator
and the discernment would be say yup
looks like a person yeah so stylegan
stylegan2 other techniques for doing
this and they create
highly highly realistic images of people
and now we're even starting to have
control where you can play with the
gender
and the race and the age and the
features on it so it's not just a random
person
but you start to have some controls on
it the way you would in a cgi world
now that's one type of deep fake a
static image we'll talk a little bit
about where that type of technology is
being weaponized
but let's talk a little bit because
that's what what the bulk of the work
we're going to talk about is our deep
fake videos
is a deep fake video so now imagine
taking that same
generative adversarial network
generative because you're building
something adversarial because you're
pinning these two systems against each
other
and of course underneath each of these
is a deep neural network
so now imagine we're going to do
something a little bit different we're
going to take this image of jennifer
lawrence
the the performer and we want to change
her face
to be that of steve buscemi why steve
buscemi
i mean why not you know just anybody it
could have been
so now what we're going to do is the
following this generator has to change
her identity to his identity and it does
it by
modifying some pixels handing it to the
discriminator
the discriminator says can i
discriminate that person from
the actor steve buscemi while keeping
the appearance of the image the same
so his head should be down and to the
left his eyes should be slightly closed
the the appearance of the lighting and
the texture should be the same
all i want to do is change identity and
again you do this in a very very very
tight loop
and if you do that over and over again
frame after frame
after frame you get something that looks
like this so original videos here
a face swap deep fake is here where
steve buscemi has been mapped onto
jennifer lawrence's face there's
actually an audio track here i've just
taken it out so i can talk over it
so a couple of things first of all who
would have guessed that steve buscemi
says a good looking woman i mean it
looks fantastic here
and notice how seamless this is um is
that the lighting looks really good the
expression looks really good the head
movements
everything is moving and just on every
single frame all that has been done
is we've done a face swap deep fake
frame after frame after frame
after frame by the way if you haven't
seen some of these there are really
really good examples on youtube my
favorite one just came out a few weeks
ago
it's uh sylvester stallone and arnold
schwarzenegger have been spliced into
the movie
step brothers and it is very very funny
and very well done slightly not safe for
work but very well done
so this is one type of deep fake uh
where we've replaced a person's face
typically from the eyebrows
to the chin um from one face to another
there are two others let me just mention
them briefly because i'll talk about
them later
there is a puppet master deep fake so
here what we do is we take a single
image of a person
and then i am the puppet master so as i
sit in front of the camera
and move my eyebrows and turn my head
and smile
and talk it animates that single image
now some beautiful work coming out of
the university of southern california
from hal lee's group
on doing that a lip sync deep fake is
slightly different
here we take an original video and we
have a new audio stream
either synthesized or just an
impersonator
and all that's re-synthesizes the mouth
to be consistent with a new audio track
so whether it's the mouth the entire
head or just the face
each of these deep fakes what are we
doing we're trying to make somebody say
and do something that they didn't right
either for comedic purposes
to interfere with the democracy or to
commit large-scale fraud by getting mark
zuckerberg to say that his profits are
down
by 20 and trying to move the stock
market yeah
so where are we seeing before i talk so
the game we play here is we don't create
these things we want to detect them and
why do we want to detect them well
because we think that these can be
weaponized
so where are we currently seeing
weaponization of deep fakes
single i don't think it will shock you
sadly single most
common use of deep fakes is in the
creation of non-consensual pornography
a woman's likeness is superimposed into
sexually explicit material
and then that material is distributed
online this is probably the most common
form of it and in fact it is where the
term
deep fake came from it is deep fake is
the the handle name
of a reddit user who used this
technology to create the first
non-consensual pornography big big
problem for performers famous people
but also a problem for journalists human
rights
activists people who simply attract
unwanted attention there have been
examples
have very high profile cases of very
powerful women
who have tried to speak truth to power
and have been harassed with this type of
content it is awful
and many of the big platforms have not
figured out or are not willing to figure
out
how to contend with that we are all
living through highly complex and
intricate misinformation campaigns
meant to sow civil unrest meant to
interfere with democratic elections
for the purposes of trolling or for
fraud and these types of images and
video
are simply adding fuel to that fire so
for example my favorite example of the
use of
a face synthesized using this person
does not exist was that
last year 17 year old kid in florida was
bored during his holiday break
and he created a fictional candidate for
congress in rhode island
he got that candidate approved by the
election board
and got an approved twitter account
using a face of the candidate that was
synthesized using
this person does not exist he created a
completely fictional character
that as far as anybody knew actually
existed
we've seen these types of faces being
used and misinformation campaigns to
create
fictional profiles on facebook on
linkedin and on twitter to create
credibility
as people create fraudulent accounts
there are entire websites now by the way
where you can pay somebody a buck 99 to
create any type of face that you want or
you can just download it for free from
this person does not exist
as ted will tell you i got into this
business because i was worried about the
courts
so 20 years ago you know we didn't have
the internet that we had today we didn't
have non-consensual pornography we
didn't have
even the concept of fake news the way we
do today but we were worried about how
we introduced digital evidence into a
court of law
and this creates a big problem for how
do we trust
the digital evidence whether it's an
image an audio recording or a video
being introduced into a court of law
obviously on the national security scale
we are constantly on a daily basis being
inundated with
visual imagery from around the world in
places that we can't physically be
and we have to make things that have
huge impacts on the world around us
how do we do that when we don't know if
we can trust the visual imagery that we
see
fraud i've already mentioned it i create
a video of jeff bezos saying amazon
stocks are down
ten percent of uh profits are down ten
percent how long do you think it'll take
me to move the market a few billion
dollars before anybody figures out that
that video is fake
uh we've already seen the first example
of this a ceo was um
uh was uh lost 250 million dollars or
250 million euros
uh because somebody had created a
synthetic voice over a phone call saying
why are this amount of money per this
person's approval
they wired the money quarter million
dollars was lost from a synthetic voice
so all of these things are either here
today
or we are probably going to be seeing
them in the coming years and this gives
us a little bit of concern
for how these types of deep fakes can be
weaponized and this is what we want to
think a little bit about is how do we
detect these
okay so i'm going to talk about some of
the work that shruti has been doing on
this front just one of the techniques
that we've been
uh developing so i'm going to show you
in the next slide a series of
clips of former president obama they're
just
short little two to three second clips
from
his weekly address i've ripped out the
audio just so i can talk over it so
you're gonna see
a little clip after a little clip after
a little clip and then each one of those
clips he's saying
hi everybody hi everybody it's the very
beginning of his
weekly address see if you notice
anything
during the clips
so every one of these again he's saying
hi everybody hi everybody hi everybody
hi everybody hey everybody
okay so those are all distinct clips i
could have done that for another 20
minutes or so and i don't know if you
noticed it
but every time he did it there's this
little
tilt of the head up into the back right
and you can see it here he's coming down
so every time he says hi everybody says
hi everybody and you can see it right
here on that slide he purchases his lips
ever so slightly
and then he starts talking almost every
single weekly address
he starts exactly the same way when
shooti first
showed me this this is actually a small
version of the longer version i was sure
she had duplicate in it because it
didn't seem like they could have all
been distinct
those are all distinct little videos so
what is that
it's a little behavioral mannerism it's
a little tick yeah
i have mine by the way i've been doing a
lot of zoom talks i've been noticing
them
how i raise my eyebrows when i emphasize
i tend to move forward when i want to
emphasize something
president obama does this thing where he
does you know when he says hey everybody
he does this he has other ones let me
give you an example of that
here's my favorite one so what i'm
showing you here is one frame from an
authentic
obama video and on this graph what i'm
showing you
along the horizontal axis is time this
is about 10 seconds so roughly let's
call it 250 frames or so
and in blue i'm plotting how much obama
is rotating his head around the
horizontal axis as if
in the affirmative nodding in the
affirmative yeah that's the blue graph
uh curve right there the orange curve
is how much he is frowning so the sides
of his mouth are turning
downward yeah and this is averaged over
an hour or so of video and what do you
notice they're
correlated yeah so obama has this
interesting mannerisms
and you can see it now um when you go
back and watch some of the speeches
that when he delivers bad news when he's
angry
when he's sad when he's upset he does
this
and he frowns and there's a slight
tilting of the head downward
when he speaks yeah it's very consistent
and it's a very interesting
again behavioral mannerism why do i care
about behavioral mannerisms we'll get to
that in a minute
okay but now let's think about uh a lip
sync deep fake so what was a lip sync
deep fake
i replaced his mouth with a new mouth
that has been synthesized
saying something else while his head was
saying well whatever it was saying in
the
original video same thing time on the
horizontal axis
10 seconds blue is rotation of the head
up and down
orange is frowning what's wrong here
they're decoupled why well because the
head was saying what the head was saying
in the original video
but the mouth is saying well whatever
the mouth is saying in the
synthesized audio and although it looks
all fine the mouth is doing what it
should be doing and the head is sort of
doing something
i've created this chimera of sorts it's
not it's not the head doesn't know what
the mouth is doing
and the mouth doesn't know what the head
is doing and i've disrupted
that behavioral mannerism now
that's obama's yeah this guy has a
different behavioral mannerism
okay so same thing time 10 seconds in
blue now
is this chin pucker that trump does i
actually can't do it very well i don't
know how he does he was this weird thing
with his chin if you've seen him talk
and the orange going up here is this you
know this thing he does with his mouth
when he talks
yeah and what do you notice here is that
they're
decorated so when he chunk chin puckers
his mouth is closed
when his mouth is open he doesn't chin
pucker right they're decorated
all right uh alec baldwin doing trump
and saturday night live we created a
face swap deep fake so that's trump's
face
slapped on to alec baldwin yeah
what's going on with alec baldwin ah so
he's got like the individual
characteristics of trump right in their
mouth
but he correlates them yeah so he's got
that
sort of caricature of trump but he
didn't get
the dynamics right or the correlation
right
and so what we're going to do is we're
going to explore various people
obama trump harris biden
warren pick your favorite candidate
senator
president prime minister ceo whomever it
is and we're going to learn what their
mannerisms are and we're going to try to
use
that to distinguish them from
impersonators so fundamentally
we're not really going after deep fakes
what i'm going after is whether it's a
face swap whether it's a lip sync
whether it's a puppet master
it's an impersonator it is whoever is
doing these actions either you've
disrupted the natural
dynamics of the head the mouth the
expressions or it's just not them it's
somebody else's driving
the mannerisms okay so here's what we're
gonna do
uh i i think i've already said that with
the lip sync deep fake
you disrupt what the mouth and head are
doing they don't know about each other
and for the face swap and the puppet
master it's somebody else moving
it's somebody else's mannerisms even if
it looks like somebody else
and we're going to use that we're going
to try to exploit that as a soft
biometric
to distinguish real from fake so here's
what we're going to do
take a video do standard face tracking
so
here the blue box gives me 3d
orientation uh the red dots that you see
around the face
give me facial features from which i
will extract
18 so-called action units so these tell
me are you lifting your eyebrows are you
frowning are you smiling
so these various standard action units
so for
every moment in time as i'm tracking
that video over a 10 second window
roughly 250 frames
i extract these 18 action units and two
head rotations
rotation like this and rotation like
this
we ignore this rotation around the
vertical axis because politicians do
this a lot
and as they're scanning the audience and
it's not diagnostic
yeah okay so we have 20 measurements
that we make
that gives us 20 choose 2 20 times 19
divided by 2 190 pairs
of expressions and head movements
similar to what i showed you for trump
similar what i showed you for obama just
look at the
correlation or anti-correlation of
facial expressions okay so
so every 10 second clip
i look at 190 correlations and i get a
single number out for each of those 190
correlations
so every 10 second clip is now a point
in 190 dimensional space
which of course we can't visualize i'm
going to slam that into this
two-dimensional space here and every
data point here is a 10-second video
clip for
kamala harris hillary clinton elizabeth
warren bernie sanders
et cetera et cetera so this work was
obviously done during the democratic
primary
what do you notice oh by the way these
um all these ones scattered in here
these are random people taken from
something called the face forensic
database it was part of a larger testing
that we were doing so you know you can
ignore
those but these clumps that you see here
are all individuals
even in this two-dimensional space this
is an original 190 dimensional space
you see this very nice tight clustering
so kamala harris all the videos cluster
together
obama o'rourke booker trump sanders
warren et cetera
so how do we how do we exploit this so
what does it tell us by the way is that
people are pretty consistent
and they're distinct from each other we
found this if you will
soft biometric and i say soft because i
don't think i'm going to distinguish
kamala harris from 7 billion people in
the world
but i don't have to i just have to
distinguish her from a impersonator
so here's what we're going to do we're
going to we do this in the full 190
dimensional space but we can visualize
it here
we build a simple one class non-linear
support vector machine
nothing fancy you know no neural nets
nothing nothing complicated here
so we have a bounding surface around
the authentic obama videos and then any
10 second clip
face track extract action units and head
movements 190 correlations
put a point into the space and are you
within the bounding surface or not if
yes
authentic if not not authentic and
notice by the way
these data points are the deep fake
obama they're close
but they're outside and if you're
outside of here
it's not that you're a deep fake it's
just that you're not obama
but that's all i care about if i'm
looking at a video and it looks like
obama
i just want to know are the behavioral
mannerisms are the temporal dynamics
unfolding over a 10-second window
consistent with the mannerisms of obama
or harris or clinton
or whomever okay so let me show you how
this uh
some large-scale testing so we have a
number of different data sets i'll give
you specific numbers in a minute
uh original obama super easy to get just
go on youtube and scrape youtube you can
get hours and hours and hours of video
of obama
uh we have some colleagues and friends
up at the university of washington
create some lip
sync deep fakes of obama so now just the
mouth has been replaced with a new audio
track
there's a very good impersonator on
youtube of obama this is
not a deep fake it's just somebody
pretending to be obama he's very funny
um from that our friends at the
university of southern california
how lee and his group created face swap
deep fakes where we swapped obama's face
onto the impersonator's video
and sorry uh yeah they did that and then
also the usc group
made a bunch of puppet master deep fakes
where somebody one of the graduate
students in howe's lab
um was just sitting in front of the
camera animating uh obama
so we have one two three deep fakes
those are the three that i enumerated
earlier
we just have an impersonator because if
we can detect the differences
it doesn't matter whether it's just a
real video but it's somebody who's not
obama or it is in fact a deep fake
and then of course we have the authentic
videos
all right so here's how i'm going to
show you the results i'm going to ask
what is the ability to distinguish
authentic obama videos of which there's
about 207
000 10 second clips from random people
these are primarily newscasters
the comedic impersonator that i just
showed you earlier and the three types
of deep fakes the numbers under each of
these are the number of
10 second video clips that we're going
to try to categorize
again i don't have to learn using this
data this is pure testing data
i train on this data authentic and it's
a one-class support vector machine so
anything that falls out
is not obama whether it's a random
person a comedic impersonator or a deep
fake
i'm going to present the results as area
under the curve
0.5 means i'm a chance i'm guessing
whether it's real or fake
1.0 means i've got a perfectly a perfect
classifier
all right let's see how we did okay so
for random people
comedic impersonators face swap and
puppet master
we're roughly an auc of 0.95
yep so that's pretty good not perfect
but pretty good
on a single 10 second clip by the way
that's that's actually not bad that's
all i'm working on is a 10 second clip
we took a big hit here we're at around a
little bit above 0.8 on lip sync
why is that by the way what does that
make sense so first of all
sure what's the nature of a lip sync
deep fake is all i've done is replace
the mouth
the rest of the head is authentic so how
he's moving his head and his eyebrows
is obama and so in fact most of the
mannerisms here are perfectly fine so it
makes sense
that with these deep fakes and for
people who are not obama we should do
better but here we do worse
i won't show you the slide for that but
if we're careful on the features that we
use
always using one action unit from the
mouth and another from the head
this can bump up to about 0.95 so we
just have to be
if we're a little careful we can get a
bump here but we can also get a bump
if we just consider that most videos
that we see are typically two to three
minutes
and so if we just simply integrate over
all of the 10 second clips in a video
just averaging you can see you get this
nice bump in the dark
uh i don't know what color that is blue
let's call it
so here with the puppet master we have
just about a 1.0
we got a nice bump on the lip sync to
above 0.9 and now we're getting really
close to perfect classification
um distinguishing only using these
behavioral mannerisms
over an average of a two to three minute
video two and a half minute video rather
um of obama now that's for obama of
course
um i will tell you i don't have the
slide for this apparently is that
we've done this for hillary clinton
we've done it for kamala harris we've
done it for joe biden we've done it for
bernie sanders we've done for donald
trump
and the accuracies are almost exactly
the same there's almost no difference
except one exception
we're really really good at detecting
elizabeth warren um
fakes and the reason is she is so
incredibly animated if you've ever seen
her talk
you are all from massachusetts she is
just
really super animated and nobody can
reproduce that animation so we do
really really well on elizabeth warren
i'm slightly better than everybody else
um so this generalizes to various people
it's not just an obama classifier
now i'm aware uh that we are living
through a machine learning
uh revolution or i should say the third
machine learning revolution and i
understand that
it's very popular to throw machine
learning and problems
um i think it's really nice to
understand what it is
that we've learned um and so it's nice
that we can look at this and say look
we've learned this behavioral mannerism
that has to do with
how people move for example their head
and their mouth and for each individual
i can tell you what it is i can go in
and look
and see what are the features that are
most diagnostic so for elizabeth warren
it's
the head movement left and right as she
talks of course it is
and for trump it's something else and
for obama it's something else
i'm also aware that we've hand crafted
these features we have by hand
selected things that is almost certainly
not optimal but
learning what we've learned now let's
see if we can do a little bit better by
throwing some machine learning at it so
let me tell you a little bit about what
we did
following on that initial investigation
where we got this idea
that we could use these behavioral
mannerisms to detect
uh impersonators and deep fix so here's
what we're going to do to try to tidy
this up a little bit
and and eke out a little bit more
performance
we're going to start with fab net so
fabnet is a deep neural network
that captures the appearance of people
and basically what it does it takes a
single image and it extracts a 256
dimensional
um a vector that represents
a person's appearance okay now we we
care about time
so we're going to here i'm going to have
t equals 1 to 100 so that's 100 frames
now
so we've reduced it down to about 4
seconds from the original 10.
we did that primarily for computational
considerations because once you start
doing everything with neural networks
it gets a little more tedious so we're
now only working on four second video
clips 24 frames a second
100 frames each one of these gets shoved
through a fab fabnet
okay what does fabnet do it this
representation right here this 256
dimensional vector
is a representation of a person's
appearance so that you
if you do a query against the database
of faces
using that representation you will get
things that have a similar appearance
so for example here in the middle row
this woman is her lips are slightly
pursed
she's looking directly at the camera and
her eyes are closed the nearest
neighbors that you see to the to the
right here
using that representation are well
people who sort of look the same but
it's not
the same person most importantly here
for example the person that's slight
profile
and you get nearest neighbors are people
similarly profile but different identity
that's the whole point of fabnet is that
you are capturing
some characteristic that embodies the
appearance
of the image okay so that's not exactly
what we want but it's a step in the
right direction of what we want
so what we do is we take each frame
across four seconds we shove them into
fabnet and we get this 256 dimensional
representation
now what do we want to do we want to
capture behavioral mannerism so we
really want
time in there so that fab net is one
step
why well if my head is turned this way
and i'm frowning
that's an appearance but then what
happens in the next frame i start to
smile okay
so i want to capture that change in
appearance over time but i also care
about identity
so here's what we're going to do take
the 100 frames each one goes through
fabnet you get a 256 dimensional
representation pack that into a matrix
so now it's 100 by 256
okay that's this step right here
we're going to shove that representation
into something that we built called
behavior net
so that's that little green box right
there and out of that comes 512
dimensional vectors
i'm not going to talk about all the
nitty-gritty details about this i will
give a link at the end of the talk with
with a paper that describes this
a couple of quick things this is a
standard architecture using resnet101
we use a metric learning objective
function and a voxlub2 dataset
and what we were trying to do was the
following the objective here
was to do the following given
not just a single image but a hundred
images
four second clip we wanted to find
similar clips in terms of identity and
appearance so for example
um here and that little video clip you
can now see the rock is moving and each
person moving there's there's 100 frames
out of those hundred frames we push them
into fabnet
we push them into our behavior and now
comes a 512 dimensional
representation we then look for the
nearest neighbor
in the big data set of videos and images
that we have and we extract the most
similar
and now you see something really
interesting you see first of all
it finds the same person and the thing
that they are doing
is similar so here's the rock at slight
profile talking
um here's this guy he starts talking and
he turns his head the nearest neighbors
do the same thing
same thing on this one this woman's
talking and then she turns her head
slightly
nearest neighbors do the same thing so
the output of the behavior net
is now capturing two things identity
and behavior well that's what we want so
instead of
hard wiring the action units in the head
movements
we're now going to use that learned
representation from behavior not
and i'm simply using this visualization
to tell you that that behavior net
seems to have learned a representation
that captures both identity
and behavior mannerisms all right
so that's one pipeline everybody goes
into fabnet into blue
fabnet goes into this behavior net that
little box there could be a whole nother
talk talking about how we did that but
i'll ignore it for now
512 representation that captures the
underlying behavioral mannerisms
let me just describe another pipeline so
we're going to combine a few things in
the end
each of these image is then shoved into
a vgg
which is a standard face recognition out
of that comes a 40 96 dimensional
representation
which you can just use for face
recognition there's nothing special
about vgg we just use some some
off-the-shelf uh representation for face
recognition
um we've got a hundred of those for each
of the frames of the video we simply do
an
average why well because we expect the
face to have the same identity
so out of this pipeline in orange comes
identity
spatial static identity based on face
recognition
out of this pipeline comes behavioral
identity having to do with the
mannerisms evolving
over time and now what we want to do is
we have a reference set
of authentic videos where we know what
the who it is we know what the
mannerisms are
and we simply ask a very simple question
for this sequence
there is an identity match based on the
face
this is kamala harris we have a match
based on the behavioral mannerism who is
the closest in terms of the mannerism of
this
and then we simply ask well is it the
same person so does the mannerism
match the face and if the answer is yes
it's authentic
and if the answer is no well then we say
okay this is
it looks like kamala harris but it's not
moving like kamala harris
mismatch it's a fake so that's what
we're going to do
now let me just show you the evaluation
so we had a couple of different data
sets
what i'm plotting on here are one two
three four five data sets
in terms of the number of identities in
the data set and the
average duration of the video this is
the data set that we created that i was
just talking to you about
wldr stands for world leaders there's
only 10 identities but we have 14
000 um seconds of
per identity so we have really long uh
sequences per person this is the face
forensic database which has 10 000
people but only 19 000 19 seconds per
person
and then there's a few data sets in
between that are somewhere in between
we're going to evaluate
the behavior net that i just described
across all of these data sets
this time i'm going to present the
results in a slightly different way this
is the average accuracy across
all five data sets along here is a
parameter it's just a threshold that
allows us to know when we should make a
decision
and this is the percent correct i fear
that this might be a little small
100 is at the top zero percent is at the
bottom
crossover point um is roughly
97 across all the data sets so you can
see here 97 99
98 oops 88 i'll get back to that in a
minute and 93. so you can see the
crossover for real and
purple and fake in uh green
are in the high 90s um i don't have a
slide i'm sorry to do a comparison to
the original technique but i will tell
you we get a
five to ten percent bump relative to the
handcrafted features not as much as you
would have expected by the way i
expected the machine learning
would have learned a much more
diagnostic uh
and representative uh uh feature but in
fact it's a relatively modest bump after
all of that work
now we took a really big hit here we
went from the high 90s to the high 80s
and why
is that what is it about this data set
and i like this plot a lot because it's
a cautionary tale
when you're using these big data sets
that you download from the internet
so this is one example from the data set
the dfdc data set which was built by
uh the folks at facebook
this is uh so these were meant to be
face swap deep fakes
this is one frame of the source video
and one frame of the
target video and this is the
corresponding frame of the face swap
now what this should have been is this
person's identity
mapped onto that person's mannerisms
but that's not what happened all this is
a blurry version of this person
and so this face swap is in fact not
this person's identity
it's still this person's blurry identity
and so in fact this database is riddled
with some problems where the face swaps
just failed
um and because there's thousands and
thousands of them and the quality
control wasn't done very carefully
they're out there and so when you're
evaluating against these you have to go
back and look at your mistakes
and it turned out the data set was
actually not very good and if we
eliminate all these
we get back into the high 90s again just
a little bit of a cautionary tale
okay so uh that's one technique that
shruti
and i have been working on let me talk a
little bit about uh
going forward what's next so what are
the challenges in this space i think
everybody here probably knows that
really rapid startlingly rapid
advances and deep learning so every
three to four months frankly every time
there's a conference deadline
we see new advances in the synthesis of
fake images fake video fake audio so
it's a very very fast landscape
the problem is not of course just
creating fake content
it's the fact that that content can get
online and spread at a speed that is
unprecedented
because of social media so if the
problem was just we can create fake
content
but we have no way of distributing it to
the world instantaneously
well okay it'd still be a problem but
this is the biggest problem which is
that once this stuff is out there
once the non-consensual porn once the
misinformation once the fraudulent
content gets out there
it is very very very difficult to rein
it back in
and that's a huge challenge for us
working in this space we have a
particularly polarized public
that when videos come out people want to
believe that they're fake
um so for example when george floyd was
killed by a police officer
people claimed it was a deep fake video
because they didn't want to believe it
when the video of speaker pelosi came
out purportedly showing her drunk
people wanted to believe that she was
drunk despite the fact that it was fake
and so when you have a highly polarized
public you can very easily play into
people's preconceived notions and this
stuff works because
people want to believe it the biggest
threat here i would argue
is uh what was what is called the liar's
dividend so this is a lovely
description from danielle citron of what
happens when you enter a world where any
image
any video any audio any news story can
be fake
well then nothing has to be real anybody
can simply dismiss something as
inconvenient truth here by the way is
how fast the world has changed
rewind with me if you will to 2015 then
candidate trump
gets caught on an access hollywood tape
saying some very very bad things about
women
yeah what did he do he apologized he
actually said the words i am sorry that
is that was wrong
it's not who i am today
two years later uh 2017 now
reporter asked him about the access
hollywood tape you know what he said
it's fake one swipe of the hand gone
right that's how fast the landscape has
shifted and people's ability to say
you can't believe anything whether it's
the new york times because they're too
liberal whether it's fox news because
they're too conservative
or whether the facts simply don't
conform to your worldview
about the number of deaths of covid
about humanitarian crisis around the
world
about climate change about any of a
number of things happening in the world
you don't have to believe it if you
don't want to because once everything
can be fake
nothing has to be real i would argue
that is by far the biggest threat
that is emerging on the landscape the
net head knows this very well because
ted and i have talked about this many
times
is this is an arms race you know we do a
little bit something you do a little bit
something and the game keeps going and
we never never
quite end this game like everything else
in cyber security so it's both fast
paced
and never ending what are the
interventions
well i think that the youtubes and the
facebooks and
the tick tocks and the twitters of the
world have to start taking more
responsibility
for the mess that they've created in
society they have to stop standing
behind
we're simply the platform we are the
wire we're not responsible
i don't think anybody believes that
anymore we have to find a balance
between
dealing with the misinformation
apocalypse that is among us and having
the free and open internet that we all
want to exchange ideas
i think as we are talking about
regulation which is happening here on
capitol hill it's happening in brussels
it's happening in the uk it's happening
all over the world i would argue that we
should spend more time
talking about the recommendation
algorithms and less time talking about
the content
the fact is that the reason we have the
problem today is not because you can
create fake content
not because you can post that but
because the underlying recommendation
algorithms
favor the most outrageous divisive
hateful
conspiratorial content because it's good
for business
hate and outrage sells it keep people
engaged
engagement keeps you clicking clicking
is good for revenue
we should be talking about
recommendation algorithms more than we
should be talking about the underlying
content
obviously we need to be talking about
technological interventions and
obviously we need to be talking about
how do you educate the next
generation of young minds on how to be
better digital citizens and consume
trusted information
online this is shitty agarwal really
really wonderful
phd student who's done all the work that
i've described and many other really
beautiful things in the general space
of digital forensics let me just touch
on a few things happening in the lab
just to give you flavor for some of the
other things that we are working on
sophie nightingale is a former postdoc
she just started a job
yesterday in fact at the university of
lancaster in the uk
as a professor sophie has been doing
some very nice work over the last two
years on forensic identification
how we identify people from crime scenes
she wrote a really beautiful paper in
the proceedings of the national academy
of science uh this year
showing that um a technique used by the
fbi
in actual cases over the last few years
trying to identify people from the wear
and tear
on blue jeans is highly unreliable
despite the fact that the courts have
adopted it
and more generally we are interested in
how the these various digital forensic
techniques are being used to identify
people
whether it's based on things like
clothing or
as nirja is working on even simple
things like estimating people's height
and weight from a single photograph turn
out to be highly unreliable
so we have a big emphasis in the lab not
just on whether things are real or fake
but on how you can extract reliable
information in a forensic setting to
identify individuals
one quarter of wrongful convictions in
this country
are due to flawed forensic science both
physical
and digital that field is a bit of a
mess and
sophie and nirja and i are trying to
understand what the
landscape looks like figure out what are
the techniques that are reliable
what are not and how to make them uh
more reliable
julia dressler was an undergraduate with
me at dartmouth college
and this work is now a few years old but
i wanted to mention because it's also in
the general space of criminal justice
julia did a really beautiful
undergraduate thesis in understanding
the use of predictive algorithms and
predicting
recidivism that are being used in the
courts today both here in the u.s and
abroad
and how these algorithms have a serious
racial bias
and understanding where that bias is
coming from
and and when and if it can actually be
corrected and there's some really nice
work in a science advances paper
that julia wrote a couple years ago um
everything that i've talked about
shooti's work on the digital forensics
sophie's work and nerja's work on the
forensic science
and julie's work on algorithms can all
be found
at that website for read.berkeley.edu
and i think with that i'll stop thanks
very much
thank you very much honey that was
really wonderful
i'm gonna give you my uh applauses uh my
full applauses um so um let's see
um we have a uh we have a question um
a technical question what do you use for
dimensionality reduction
uh is it pca or yeah we did not use pca
we used um the tsne okay tsne
i don't think by the way there's
anything special there i think you could
use just about anything for that but i
think tsne slightly gives you slightly
cleaner results fabulous um
i i would like to ask you a more
conceptual
question so um how can we how can you
imagine
a technological solution for dealing
with
um with this whole fakeness
like you know we have spell checkers can
we have um
fake checkers what would it take to get
there
good i'm glad you asked us let me
preface this answer
daniella by saying that the technology
i'm about to talk about
is uh related to work that i do with a
small startup
in which i have a financial interest i
have a little bit of conflict of
interest in what i'm about to describe
to you and i think it's important to
mention that
so everything i've described is what we
falls under the category of
passive forensics you wait you sit back
and you wait for the video to hit and
then you try to figure out if it's real
or not
and that works reasonably well when it's
the new york times or the associated
press or reuters
that are willing to wait days or weeks
to get it right or it works well in the
courts of law
where you have days weeks months years
to get it right but it doesn't work well
on twitter facebook youtube and tick
tock
where things move at light speed so how
do you get to what you just said i like
that analogy by the way the spell
checker that's exactly the right way to
think about it
so the passive forensics are never going
to get there in my opinion we're never
going to have the accuracy and the speed
to be able to analyze any type of image
any type of video any type of audio at
scale
it's not going to happen so what can you
do so uh the work that is being done
that i think can scale is so-called
control capture imaging
and so here's the basic idea it's quite
simple on this device
at the point of capture either in
hardware or software
you reach into the image and you grab
all the pixels
you grab the gps tag and you grab the
date time tag and you cryptographically
sign it you take that
signature and either you just attach it
to the image or you put it onto a
blockchain type of thing and then any
point in the future
you can authenticate the image back to
the original
yeah so it's not a watermark it's not
we're not we're not inserting something
into the image which we all know has
problems because those can be
elim removed but it's a cryptographic
signature if somebody wants to remove
the signature it's fine
you just won't be able to authenticate
the image i think that's one technique
that could actually work at scale if it
was on every single device
and the good news about these things is
this is where what 99.9
of photos are taken today right we're
all taking photos on these devices now
they're all hd cameras i bet ted is
probably taking photos on these
so i think that technology can scale and
it can work
um now there are limitations to that
there are things to worry about there
are privacy issues to worry about
but if you think about the direction it
makes sense it doesn't make sense for me
to take a photo and send it to the world
and ask everybody receiving it to fact
check it
that's insane what makes more sense is
for me to take a photo
authenticate it and then put it out to
the world so
that is the technology that i think
could work but now what do you need you
need
apple and google to build it into the
devices
you need the facebooks and the youtube
and the tic tocs and the twitters and
the social medias of the world
to prioritize that content to say we
will trust content
we will prioritize trusted content over
non-trusted content
and then you have to deal with a couple
of very tricky issues which is
human rights watching like what do you
do with an investigative journalist a
whistleblower somebody who's doing human
rights
to make sure that they are not somehow
being exposed and you've got to figure
out how to add in some anonymity to that
that technology exists today um but
there's a lot of infrastructure that
would have to get built around it
thank you honey we have just a few more
minutes i want to
sneak in two more questions from the
audience can you generally tell if a
picture is fake just by trying to
identify pixel overlays
by identifying pixel overlays i'm not
sure exactly what that means so
let me answer it this way we have a
number of different techniques for
detecting
uh image manipulation that work at that
pixel level that look at things like
has this been compressed more than once
um is the color filter array
bayer pattern consistent across the
image
do you see inconsistencies in the
underlying image noise for example so
so the answer to that is sometimes yes
sometimes no
the problem with those really low level
pixel level detection schemes is that if
somebody takes an
image hd manipulates it and then
downsizes it by a factor of eight and
recompresses it to
75 jpeg compression all of those
artifacts disappear and you introduce
all these gnarly jpeg artifacts which
make
those very difficult to detect honey one
last question
um do you have any thoughts about
detecting fake audio
or fake speech to complement the fake
video yeah we've done some work on fake
audio
with one of my former phd students sway
lu who's now at suny buffalo
um it's you know i always i have to say
i'm embarrassed to say this i always
thought that when i went to go do speech
it'd be really easy because
video seems really hard and image seems
hard but not as hard as video and i just
figured
as i move down the dimensionality it
would get easier but audio is really
really hard
we have developed some techniques i
think it's somewhat of an orphan field
most of the people in my field don't
look at audio and i think there's it's
really
ripe for a lot of really interesting
questions so we've done a little bit
there's a few papers on my website about
it
there's a little bit of a literature but
it's a little it's a little neglected in
my opinion
honey that was really wonderful first of
all
great to see you second i'm so excited
to see
uh the the really um insightful research
from your group
thirdly i look forward to a better world
where
i will have the um the fake
catcher catching system um
so i won't have to worry about uh fake
images and fake videos
uh really thank you very much on behalf
of all of us
i'm going to give you some um another
round of applause
and um uh maybe you can stay on for uh
okay bye everyone see you next week
thanks everybody